so it's just like a parts video but with
some project for awesome stuff in it I
can do that but I'm I'm going to use the
format good morning Hank it's Tuesday
so I recently came across this book from
1833 called the infirmities of Genius
where it talks about authors having this
specific personality that makes them
unusually susceptible to tuberculosis
and the books like you know authors with
their eccentricities of thought and
action their waywardness peevishness
irascibility misanthropy murky passions
and thousand Indescribable
idiosyncrasies
and I took that kind of personally you
know like how am I going to respond to
somebody's accusations of pvishness and
duressability except with my trademark
peevishness and harassability okay I
think it's time to check on the weather
yeah I don't know it's okay I mean it's
a little windy the weird thing about TV
in the 19th century is that like some
mental health conditions today it was
both heavily stigmatized and heavily
romanticized like those Concepts just
aren't opposites of each other you were
told that you were like separate from
the social order and less than a full
human being but at the same time you
were also told that like you might be a
genius like your greatest Affliction
will also be your superpower like you
have to have OCD but you can be a
brilliant detective like Sherlock Holmes
there's just one problem of course which
is that OCD doesn't make you a brilliant
detective and indeed tuberculosis
doesn't make you a great writer like
authors weren't extremely susceptible to
tuberculosis because of their murky
passions and harassability they were
extremely susceptible to tuberculosis
because at the time TB was causing about
a third of all deaths in England it's
quite cold it's weird that you can see
my body but you can't like feel what's
happening inside of it like you can't
feel the cold that I feel
reminds me of something Barbara Dudek
wrote that pain is inside the body so it
leaves no trace for the historian
anyway let's just uh let's go inside oh
hi so the project for awesome starts
next Friday which is so soon and you
should make a project for awesome video
making the case that a charity you care
about should get part of the money that
we raise during the first half of the
project for us and we're raising money
for Partners in Health and save the
children and then in the second half
we'll be raising money for Charities
chosen by you and your project for
awesome video could be the reason a
charity you care about gets tens of
thousands of dollars but speaking of
money a group of Nerdfighters have come
together to raise over three hundred
thousand dollars for a matching fund so
that everybody who donates to the P for
a during the p4a can get their donations
matched if you want to join the matching
fund by donating 500 or more there is a
link in the dupe we do
so I don't know if I've mentioned this
but I've been reading a lot about
tuberculosis recently and one of the
things that I learned is that the Inuit
Chinese Arabic and English words for
soul or spirit all derive on some level
from the word for breath like the word
inspiration literally means to Breathe
In To Be Inspired is to take in air and
to be expired is to be unable to take in
air I just find our relationship with
air to be exceptionally strange
especially when you consider that for
the longest time we didn't even know
that air was made out of stuff it's just
so weird that everything is made out of
stuff but we don't know why there is
stuff in the universe like we know the
exact speed of light we know what the
universe was up to two minutes after the
big bang started but we don't know why
there is matter
what a metaphorically resonant situation
to be in sometimes I'll notice there's a
high-pitched omnipresent humming sound
somewhere in the house and then I'll
track the sound to a particular light
fixture and turn that light off and just
feel this
huge wave of relief you don't even know
how loud the noise is until the noise
goes away
which is another metaphorically resonant
situation to be in Hank happy project
for awesome I'll see you on Friday